it's good to be here in the
air-conditioning it's hot out for
November you know warm weather is one
reason I came to California years ago I
don't know how many years I've lived
here I've never seen a leaf drop years
fly by okay
the seasons are nearly indistinguishable
which makes it very difficult for me to
know when to be in shape
honestly thankfully I'm from Ohio so
there's always gonna be haters which
makes me biologically Midwestern so even
if it is a very warm winter my body
knows it knows what to do and I just
start to build up a meat coat you know I
don't even thank you it looks good on me
I know I don't even weigh myself anymore
I just ask somebody to draw me and if
they reach for a marker I know I've gone
too far
[Music]
on the other hand if they draw a stick
figure
I agree so I once dated a guy that I
caught eating his booger in his defense
there was still a little bit of cocaine
left in it but yeah it is it's a bad
sign it is it's a bad time when you wish
your boyfriend just ate regular books
now I'm terrified of hard drugs you know
I'll have an occasional beer sure I'll
take a little toot on the weed horn
absolutely but the closest that I've
come to doing cocaine is just trying to
pet a guinea pig in a cage have you done
that oh my god they're in there running
around kicking up chips oh what a rush
you guys sure you want to be laughing at
a woman YouTube who's gonna see this so
yes I had guinea pigs growing up we kept
him in our garage and in the hot Ohio
summers they definitely died in there
now my sister Hannah reminded me that we
had named one of them brownie
which in retrospect is extra sad she was
out there straight bacon at 375 my mom
felt awful she let us give him a proper
burial in the backyard so we found the
easiest place to dig we buried him right
in the sandbox and then a neighborhood
dog came along smelt him snarfed up
their carcasses it was a tragedy all
around and I really feel like I could
have been avoided if we just had a dad
now
I don't know what dads do but I assume
it's regulate the garage temperature
when my parents split my dad moved down
to Orlando Florida to be an actor it's
not where you go and then my mom
replaced him with a small dog named
Nigel okay
he is a Cavalier King Charles Spaniel
she loves him I feel like all he does is
try to eat her food and put his dick on
our good pillows it's really more like a
boyfriend now that I've said it out loud
she likes to just text message photos of
him to me which she couldn't do before
cuz she's have a little flip phone thing
and she broke it I would imagine by
charging the crap out of it it was just
like constantly in the wall and she'd
say is that enough and I would say it's
been enough it's a mobile phone you're
supposed to take it places Diane either
that or she just like broke it by
pressing its buttons far too hard have
you ever seen a woman in her mid 60's
turn on a TV with a remote is it on and
then off so yeah that's her problem it's
a quick touch you're in you're out
I told a story about my mom being a bit
inept with her phone on National Public
Radio for a live audience she loved it
but afterwards I had a group of very
angry 65 year old women I think they're
called a gaggle and they came up to me
and they're like like an angry mob with
torches except the torches were just the
flashlights they didn't know we're on on
their phone
and they said you're ageist and I said
whoa you know that wasn't a TEDTalk
right I didn't say if you're over 65
kill yourself it was a joke you know
they said well we have iPhones we're in
our 60s and we know how to yield um and
I say cool cool prove it so I had them
enter my information into their cell
phones
I had them shoot me a little text
message I put us into a group text and
every Wednesday since I've just shot off
a new dick pic I feel like if you're
gonna talk the talk you better walk the
walk ladies can you all know that you
know how to use your phone when you
learn how to block my number
[Applause]